on the hill tonight is that gentleman
right there
that is tyler anderson
and tyler anderson coming off a really
solid start his last out got him
change-up and a good one
and a fast ball up and can tell knocks
it into the left-field corner dickerson
over to cut it off and martay
has a one out double continues walk the
bases lotus belt got into the game
to play defense last night but he did
not get in it bad and he's swinging the
bat pretty good right now a little jam
shot
they're going to get the out there and
they're going to throw down to second
and they get to double play
and the giants score a run it's one
nothing
but when it's all said and done the
d-backs have to be very happy with that
sugar on the ground that's a fair ball
crawford's on the move it misses that
little cutout down the right field line
and crawford's going to be held at third
the giants have runners at second and
third with
two outs
but still only one base hit
swing of the miss zach gallon strikes
out yastrimsky
and strands two it stays one nothing
giant
on the first pitch kevin krohn pops it
up
belt puts it away
and that'll bring up carson kelly
a little jam shot i don't think
anybody's gonna get there no it's belle
two puts it away don't bet against the
big fella just like a tight end
got him again and that's the fifth time
calhoun is struck out
the 2-1 to trump
trump hits it into right center field
and it's going to fall in front of
calhoun
so trump has got a lead off single first
base runner for the giants
since duggar's double in the second
right at the knees with a fastball
and then strikeout number six for gallon
and
says it's down
that's hit to the right side martay gets
it and throws to walker
and they get the out at first christian
actually fell down had to get himself up
to get to the bag to
take the throw from marte they get the
out on dickerson that'll in the inning
this one goes the other way yustrinski
on the move ball's starting to carry and
you stretch
the cage
up against the wall to take extra bases
and a run
away from the d-backs
what a great play
belt base hit left field sometimes it
looks so easy
yes it does
there's another one on the ground right
to crawford
i throw and belt comes off the bag says
adam hammery at first
two and two
and he's hit can tie the ball game
and there it is it's into right
yastrenski bobbles the ball
starling will score and we're tied at
one
just the second hit for the diamondbacks
and their first since the first inning
center field moving back is martay still
moving back still moving back and it's
off the top of the wall
and they're going to hold up crawford as
bart missed the home run by inches
[Applause]
and the walk and the giants take the
lead
can't defend that
here's dickerson
and the walk
gift after gift after gift
solano has been a great late inning
hitter this year get on the ground to
third
they're gonna get one there and that's
all
and another run comes in it's four to
one as dubon scores
[Applause]
seven walks
issued to the giants tonight by d back
pitching
brandon belt will be the first hitter
that widener will face
the giants have
yostremski at third
and solano at first the one two is
drilled into right center field by belt
that's going to get down base hit one
hop to marte who cuts it off yostremski
into score around second heading for
third solano he's there safely brandon
belt with a
line drive single to knock in another
run it's 5-1
he's had 76 starts who's never been here
it's a big deal
[Applause]
solano's got it
as he flips this one away from
crawford but no harm won out thank you
shift
out into center field
for dubon
duvan will catch
tyler anderson is thinking man am i glad
i'm not in denver because that might be
gone
that's true get on the ground to
crawford
and anderson's gonna do it
so there's a complete game three hitter
for tyler anderson
and at some point he's gonna smile
it's such a gift and i love the fact
that gabe kaplan gave him the
opportunity he absolutely did